they are both a favorite of locals
and tourists because of their tasty
farm-to-table menu but they are also
known for their farm table dinners and
they have another one coming up joining
us to tell us more is honey salted
executive chef sterling buckley welcome
back thank you thank you so good to have
you and we are making some tastes that
remind us of cape cod right yes that's
what the farm table is it's based on
cape cod so what we're going to do here
is we're going to do one of our the
entree for it it's like a boil i love
this bake if you if you don't if you
aren't familiar with honey salt where
have you been one but two
owners elizabeth
blau and chef kim cantonwalla they love
to vacation in cape cod and so that's
what kind of inspired this right right
so we kind of like take their travel to
cape cod and we kind of make menus based
off of it you know i sit down with
elizabeth and kim and we talk about it
and we just come up with some cool ideas
every time so we're doing here we're
just searing off the seafood
we've got some nice shrimp and
lobster and then we're going to go with
some prince edward island mussels in
here now this is all going to be part of
a big farm to table dinner that you guys
have coming up in on september 19th and
tell us a little bit about what you guys
do you make all this stuff yes so it's
pretty much just like a special menu we
shut down the restaurant from normal
service and we kind of do just like a
cool menu and um like the staff gets
really involved it's a lot of fun for
everybody and we just kind of we kind of
just make this cool funky menu and it
serves family style so you get to kind
of have a little conversation with your
friends and family and meet new people
i've been before you just sit with
people that you may not know and it is
so much fun okay i just saw the garlic
go in that's oh yeah you got it
so we've got some garlic in here then i
season the seafood with some old bay
okay
and then we're gonna put some rice in
here so it's kind of like almost like a
paella
in a sense now that rice is not cooked
is it no because we're gonna bake it
right in the oven oh and it's gonna it's
gonna do its thing
that is like a a cool take on a paella
east coast
almost like like a portuguese style port
paella and so we're going to take all
this
put this one in here
i love this and it's like you cram it in
there it's going to go in the oven
anyways it's all going to bake and i'm
pouring this
liquid right over the top and you can
get this at the farm
table the cape cod inspired one how do
people get their tickets so they can be
a part of this amazing thing well they
can either call the restaurant or we
have we sell tickets on thunder ticks so
they can uh they can find it like that
but um best way is called restaurant oh
yeah it's definitely a favorite so you
just bake this and then boom magic is
made actually let's go ahead and do that
now
do you have you have one ready to go i
actually have one ready to go because
that's that's the type of guy
professional i love this let's see what
we've got he's gonna take it out put
this in the oven let it do his thing and
then i have one right over here chef
that i've had ready
just for you oh
perfect look at that do we have uh
something i can still absolutely this
one's nice and clean okay we're gonna
give it a taste rocky i uh i know you're
jealous right now but
um
you just
just threw that together in a pan sure
did jeff
you're the best
go check them out honey salt one of the
best restaurants in las vegas i'll send
it over to you rocky yeah okay mercedes